our vision is not only to build an
industry but to build an industry that
will make the Israeli Financial Services
Market more competitive
more elaborate more price competitives
so every Israeli citizen will enjoy the
fruits of the Ingenuity of the companies
in the same way he does in agriculture
or in in his Hospital
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today I am with shmuel bentovin
director of fentic Il and the president
of the Israel fintech Center shmuel is
the director of entakiel innovation
community and the president of the
Israel fintech Center the largest and
most influential fintech group in Israel
his career has encompassed both the
private and public sectors among his
previous positions Minister for economic
Affairs the Embassy of Israel London
assistant director General the bank Lumi
group chief economic advisor to the
minister of Industry trade and tourism
Israel's Hansel and trade commissioner
to the United States directly elect
mayor of
small has served as a director in
leading Israeli corporations including
dezek and the Israel chemicals LTD he
holds a ba in economics and an MBA from
the Hebrew University
you have such an awesome career Journey
working on so many different things
working and municipality and Ministries
and embassies and different
organizations at executive levels today
you're the director of Kentucky and the
president of the Israel fintech Center
and defend the community of Israel so
I'm really looking forward to just
understanding a little bit better what
that means and what you're doing today
and how that plays into the different
things you've done throughout your
career so again welcome to 20 minute
leaders and tell me a little bit about
yourself what really excites you and
what what really what were your really
curious about
okay first of all I can't do anything in
my life without question
so if I do something for a time and I
feel that I'm losing attention I'm
looking for the next challenge
so I always say that I'm the nightwear
of the Jewish mother who likes her you
know son to be in one place and get a
nice pension after 40 years so I'm not
that kind of a guy
and I think if I can testify I'm I'm an
entrepreneur in my spirit
mostly a social entrepreneur rather than
being a business entrepreneur but in
whatever I do it can be an official job
it can be an NGO it can be a private
sector job I always try to do something
that has not been done before
and I think my my definition of an
entrepreneur
is someone who looks and sees something
that other people don't see
and I would add don't see yet because if
they don't see it forever you're only a
lunatic but if you can see something
before other people can identify and see
your vision then you're on the right way
and I think that the current
Mission the time in and the feedback
Association is is a good example because
I started it nine years ago
by myself and two or three friends
and most people that held what I had in
mind there thought okay the guy is a bit
of struck and today with 5 000 people in
our Network wow with about 30 countries
in our Global Network
and we say activities that how to
believe that only a handful of people
are pushing
when people are chasing us and not the
other way I feel that I've done
something wrong it took time and some
frustrations so the way you can't deny
it
but at the end of the day what I thought
is something that should be done eight
to nine years ago is happening a big win
so I'm I'm very happy
incredible okay take me back nine years
ago to to the vision of the finta
community what what is sort of the need
that you identified nine years ago that
led you to this
okay the roots uh go back to my term as
the minister for economic Affairs in the
embassy of physically in London
uh when I was of course in current
relations with the city of London with
all the major Financial players
and I tried to see ourselves in their
eyes what do they see in Israel for sure
they didn't see in Israel a Global
Financial Center we're tiny we have to
admit it but even the financial people
looked up to us when technology was
involved they said you're so good in
military Technologies in agriculture in
medicine in all walks of life it can't
be that you don't excel in this and if
you don't you're probably not putting
your efforts in the right way
and at one point it's a it's a long
story but I tried to put together an
Advisory Board who would lead us away
and my boss is in Jerusalem said look if
you have about 15 people in the group
that would be nice
so I said to myself I invite
60 70 80 people that I know in London
from all the financial district and and
other people and they'll probably have
at you know 15 notes and that would be
very nice I got 65 years to the idea of
Israel as a leader in financial
technology
everyone was you know amazed I was less
amazed because I felt that this was in
the era
when I came back to Israel I tried to
see what we need to do in order to make
it a reality something make it a
business
and we already had two very interesting
beginnings
which I brought with me from London and
this was the development and r d centers
of Citibank and Barclays under a special
program that the government designed for
them
and when I look at those huge banks that
hardly do any business in Israel don't
see you know branches of city and bodies
on the High Street in Israel but they
still thought that Israel is the right
place for them to be to seek the
technology of the new generation for
their own businesses and this was a very
very interesting indication
now I thought that the way to go about
it is not to put the assignment of the
government or Municipality of someone I
thought that the vision of the social
Society the vision that an ecosystem
should be built with everyone who has a
really deep should take apart in it it
is government this municipalities The
Regulators investors Banks
Academia Consultants everyone who has a
vested interest in developing fintech in
Israel should be part of it and this is
the concept that I've built this NGO and
it's very true to this very day so when
you look at the Israel fintech Center
you see within the all these different
people around it sitting for the first
time around the same table
not in a confrontational way but you
know effort to build something together
and of course there are many challenges
on the way we can talk about them later
on but but I think that I don't have to
prove anymore that fintech is an
industry that Israel should be in it is
already in we have so many unicorns
already in fintechs although I look at
the 700 and more finte companies most of
them in early stages and I think that
the future is done
what is the integration of the community
within the fintech sector the the you
know the tech sector how do you what is
sort of what are sort of the the
interesting inflection points or
intersection points between the
community and and the the industry that
we're in
okay I think that what
really uh separates the fintech industry
from other Tech and verticals is a
regulation
and what I mean by that
I mean that if you look at the let's say
the Cyber industry may be very close to
that you look at checkpoint you look at
other good examples
in most cases you know that from the
very beginning they realize that Israel
is not the market for them it's too
small but it's a fantastic Market to
test their Concepts to do their vlcs and
it's the same in medicine in agriculture
in defense everywhere
something small in Israel looking around
you you know learning the right lessons
and then go to the main Market abroad in
fintech it doesn't happen not because
anyone directed in this way but because
the regulation in Israel though changing
and improving still is very conservative
the structure of the financial regulator
is something that doesn't make any sense
to anyone
so most fintech companies in their very
very early stage need to go and face the
international market
even if they are too small and too and
very un under Finance to do that
and this puts a lot of pressure
on a system that can support them first
of all by mentorship second by raising
funds for them and maybe most
importantly connecting them with the
right people around the world first of
all to do their pocs and to start the
first steps and see that they have
something in hand and of course later on
probably without an NGO they can do it
by themselves go to NASDAQ and go to a m
A's and we see so many Fantastic
examples already
what we are trying to do is really build
the local ecosystem in a way that you
know names like pioneer or etoro or
lemonade
which Israelis know only if they read
the financial Pages they don't know it
from day to day life
but those kind of brands are very common
all over the world
so it it is really drives me crazy from
time to time that an American Consumer
enjoys the services and the competition
and the and the and the rates that
Israeli companies have built technology
for
while the Israeli consumer don't know
what they're talking about
and this is a very important message
that you can do only or deliver only
together with The Regulators together
with the old institutions the Legacy
institutions with all the oppositions
that they are there and all the
difficulties
that's a way to do it so our vision is
not only to build an industry but to
build an industry that we make the
Israeli Financial Services Market more
competitive
more elaborate more price competitives
so every Israeli citizen will enjoy the
fruits of the Ingenuity of the companies
in the same way he does in agriculture
or in in his Hospital
and this this this takes time
so you were mentioning a little bit
about the challenges so tell me a little
bit what you're facing with this
so I I think that's one of the very
interesting things that we have done
besides being an NGO is taking part in a
government center last year
and the government has started a
minister of economy is leading the
effort Innovation communities in many
verticals may be the best known of them
is e-commerce for smart Mobility but
there are others and last year they
decided to start an innovation community
in fintech and the published a tender so
who is going to run the show for the
government
and we applied and very fortunately we
won it and these boots are since last
November
in a steering committee together with
all the key players these are the
Ministry of Finance Ministry of economy
the Bank of Israel is on Securities
Authority The Innovation Authority
digital Israel they are all sitting with
us around the table to try to
fulfill this vision and this gives us
besides being conducted so well to to
the market
also a unique point of access to where
the decisions are being named and this
is goes two ways it goes first of all we
can project to The Regulators into the
government Ministry what are the needs
of the industry and what they should be
doing in order to have the vision to
accomplish and the other hand it allows
us to talk on half of the bear
Regulators to the industry
and to explain to them that some of the
things that look to them as complete
Madness have some sense behind it to
protect the consumer to to keep the
stability of the of the financial sector
and the banks
etc etc so we have to be you know like a
like a policeman in a in a very very
busy Crossroad to try to see the
interest of all and to try to integrate
it to one action plan and this on top of
what we've been doing in the last seven
or eight years which is more in the
typical way of an NGO how it works
wow and you asked me about my my
background of digging I feel that in
that mission I really bring the lessons
and my experience for everything that
I've been doing because I was with the
government and I was with a bank and I
was entrepreneur by myself and I was in
Israel and I was in two emissions abroad
months in New York and then in London
so I think that everything and I love to
I love people I've been doing business
with people like communicating these
people
so I find it
like a government of everything that I
was doing in my life goes down into into
this so I first of all enjoyed as I said
before he said there was no passion I'm
not there
and second I feel that we are slowly but
surely
moving moving forward
um
you know we are involved also in some
social issues we call it fainted for
good and we have now two main efforts
one is fintech for the third age for the
old people and the other one is fintic
solutions for the Arab community of
Israel both are communities that are
less involved even compared with other
sectors of the population
with financial technology and financial
Innovation and I think that if we're
able
to have such groups see the benefits of
technology to them not because they need
to catch up with the rest of their
population because it caters to the
special needs they have and that the
technology is bringing those solutions
to their dose because they're aware of
what makes them move and what are the
real needs so these are all you know
there are so many things that we can do
and we can talk for hours but I think
the essence of it is is is what I'm just
saying incredible where do you get your
own personal satisfaction today in
running this so nine years later we're
more than five thousand members where do
you really get to enjoy what you've
built here
I think the main satisfaction comes from
um being less and less the Chaser and
more and more the one who is chased
after him so uh when when you get from
really very reputable
institutions and Academia in Israel and
abroad who turn to you and have look I
heard about you I know that you're doing
ABC let's do this and this together and
sometimes those are idea that I never
heard of when they come from external
sources and they create the kind of
coalitions and and collaborations
that that are amazing I'll give you one
example from from the last three without
navigating any names a very reputable
academic institution in Israel came to
us and said look
our graduates are all sorts of them they
are fantastic
but the feedback we get is that once
they go on a job in one of the big
fintech companies they need about a year
and a half to two years to get to be
ready for the job after they completed
their MBA or the or their Computer
Sciences in the best of the Academia
they are not
Guild for the job they need a completing
a complementary kind of training let's
think about something that will do
inside the academy
the last part of any academic and degree
or training program will be in a way
that they would be doing in a company
but you know two years earlier so the
industry gets more right and and ready
people something I'm I must admit I've
never thought about that but when they
come to me and say like John forces you
bring the industry we will bring the
Academia let's build it that's something
that that excitements a lot it sounds
like not just this but throughout your
career sort of this whole integration
notion coming from a very mature
perspective of this sort of
understanding of what it takes about an
ecosystem and a community and and how
different you know stakeholders can
benefit from working with each other I
think that he sounds like it's huge part
of your journey and I love how you're
mentioning that you know it's such a
you're right you mentioned the word
Mission a few times throughout this
conversation it really feels like you
are on a mission and I really want to
thank you for not not just for this
great great episode but really for the
great work you're doing for the for the
fintech community of Israel for Israel
in general for the global ecosystem it
really is very very cool and thank you
as well for coming here on this show and
sharing your insights with me thank you
Michael my pleasure and let's meet again
soon I look forward to it thank you very
much
[Music]